and joining us now is norman solomon
co-founder of rootsaction.org and he's
here to discuss the petition sent to
Congress this week calling for an
investigation for impeachment of
President Trump Norman thank you for
joining us it's a pleasure this morning
so first tell us what is but what is
rootsaction.org we're a national online
activist group we have over a million
members now around the country and we
have been around to mobilize from the
grassroots people's concerns about a
range of issues in recent weeks we've
banded together with the organization
free speech for people to launch a
petition campaign as you mentioned for
the impeachment of President Trump and
how many signatures did you get on this
petition that he presented to Congress
well as of this morning we have 800
80,000 signers from around the United
States and we dropped off that petition
two days ago to Congressman Jamie Raskin
from Maryland on Capitol Hill at that
point we had a very tall printout of
signers of the petition 870,000 okay and
it in in we've seen a lot of petitions
that have been filed recently and over
the course of the last several years how
effective is petitioning in actually
motivating some sort of action well one
of the precepts of democracy I think is
that when people lead from the
grassroots in communities around the
country and organize effectively then
leaders will follow and I think it's
important to say that the petitions
signers that have been going to impeach
Donald Trump now org are not only
participating in signing petition but
it's the start of a national campaign
which is going to be coming to the fore
for instance next week as members hold
town hall meetings and forums around the
country so the petition is a tool and
petitions can just sit there they can be
pixels on a screen or printouts on paper
or they can be something a lot more and
in the case of the impeach Donald Trump
now campaign it's a lot more because the
changement campaign is grounded on
constitutional issues the president is
flagrantly violating the foreign
emoluments clause and the domestic
emoluments clause the latter being
article 2 section 7 which specifically
prohibits the president from the kind of
financial entanglements and conflicts of
interest that President Trump has
flagrantly said he sees as no problem as
a matter of fact the president said that
he doesn't think the President of the
United States can have a conflict of
interest maybe he heard that from
someone I don't know if it was the same
person who told him that he got the most
electoral votes since Ronald Reagan but
the reality is that on the grounds of
constitutionality and the law
impeachment is really on the approaching
horizon because the president if we're
going to have a country where nobody is
above the law and after all the
Constitution is the supreme law of the
land if we're going to have that kind of
democracy rather than moving to
dictatorship then the remedy for this
current extraordinary situation is
impeachment okay we are talking with
norman solomon the co-founder of
rootsaction.org about a petition effort
a - for impeachment of President Trump
Republicans can call two oh two seven
four eight eight thousand one Democrats
two oh two seven four eight eight
thousand and independents two oh two
seven four eight eight thousand two now
a little bit more about these petition
efforts a piece in The New York Times
points out that the biggest benefit from
a petition of one of the biggest
benefits from a petition is to raise
awareness Jason Dell can do a professor
of communications and social movement at
Temple University in Philadelphia said
in some ways it's just the updated
version of the letter-writing campaign
to arete to a representative that has
been going on for years he said do you
see this as such do you see this as a
letter-writing campaign there's a lot to
that and with the use of the internet
that can be so effective it's also for
public education and Act
activism and getting people around the
country whatever the walks of life
whatever the political party or not
being affiliated with any party being
mobilized to say I'm not just a passive
consumer of some TV show that calls
itself political but actually I can
participate and it's not only expression
to members of Congress as constituents
which is so important as ongoing
dialogue but it's also information flow
because if people go for instance to
impeach Donald Trump now org there's a
lot of information including footnoted
historical and constitutional documents
that show why impeachment is appropriate
in the case of President Trump okay and
j.r is calling in from miamisburg Ohio
on our Republican line you're on with
Norman Solomon yeah I I have a you know
you are the ones who are always talking
about our president instead of talking
good things and you know you're almost
here you have somebody on there that
wants to impeach him I voted for him I
believe in everything he has to say and
I don't want to listen to these people
that you have on there ever it seems
like it's every day you have somebody
out you better get behind the president
otherwise we're not going to have a
country and I what's urea well thank you
for your comment on the latest of public
public policy polling survey nationwide
of all registered voters shows that 46
percent support impeachment of President
Trump and 46 percent are opposed and the
rest are not sure so half of the country
now believes that President Trump should
be impeached and therefore it's going to
be inevitable that not only from me but
from many other people that you and
others around the country will hear this
being discussed rootsaction.org and also
our partners free speech for people are
nonpartisan and at rootsaction.org we
spent many many years criticizing a lot
of policies of President
Obama so that kind of independence of
thought and action I think is very
important but whether you're a
Republican a Democrat independent or a
member of a very small party we all have
a constitution of the United States and
an underlying question is whether the
president is above the law above the
Constitution of the United States and
frankly members of both parties on
Capitol Hill have pretty much dodged
that so far but they're not going to be
able to evade that question any longer
one of the characteristics of a
dictatorship is that somebody at the top
is impervious to law can be contemptuous
can go ahead and ignore any law that he
or she doesn't like and very briefly I
would recommend to you to look at
article two section seven the domestic
emoluments clause sometimes known as the
presidential compensation clause it
mentions the president the framers
including Alexander Hamilton and one of
the Federalist Papers made very clear
that this was a stringent definite
regulation that the President on
constitutional terms must be adhering to
and yet we have a president who came in
he was warned by many constitutional
scholars beginning the day after
election day that as the president-elect
he could not go ahead and be so
entangled with the Trump Organization
finances and yet here earlier this month
February fourth story with a president
already in the White House Associated
Press reported that the president Trump
is still in the direct income stream
he's supposed to have established a
fully blind trust instead with the Trump
Organization what President Trump has is
a 20/20 trust
he's totally aware of everything that is
affecting the finances and well-being of
his family and his own personal wealth
that is antithetical to the Constitution
okay Roberts calling from New Baltimore
Michigan on our independent line good
morning Robert morning go ahead your ear
on the line with Norman Solomon you know
I just had a car
I understand the whole political climate
is very hostile right now and with your
organization they're basically saying
you want to impeach Trump now if you
look at the lines of sessioned are we
going to be really heading towards a
better solution or a worse solution if
that happens because you have you have
individuals like Mike Pence you have Rex
Tillerson I mean do you really want
these kind of corrupt individuals to be
running the country well first of all if
we're going to have a country that
operates under the supreme law of the
land the Constitution then we can't pick
and choose and say okay the president
can flagrantly on an ongoing basis
violate the Constitution because we're
not too fond of the prospect of the
vice-president becoming president so
that's the constitutional and I think
the very well-grounded legal and
political answer which is that if you
give a pass to the President and say
well it's okay for you to ignore the law
then that bakes in the cake a de facto
dictatorship which certainly this
president has shown some definite
characteristics of being interested in
asserting and bringing into being but
let's approach your very good question
from a purely political standpoint if
you look back to what happened when the
House Judiciary Committee voted for the
impeachment of Richard Nixon in mid 1974
there were seven members of that
committee who were Republicans who voted
for impeachment and that showed as would
be the case with an impeachment and
removal of President Trump that if
Republicans are willing to cross that
divide and vote for impeachment then it
becomes much less of a partisan issue
let me put it to you another way and
then we'll talk for a moment about mr.
pence the only way given the majorities
in the House and Senate that President
Trump can be impeached and then removed
from office would be if substan
chill numbers of Republicans in both
houses vote to impeach and remove him
numerically it's at least 25 members of
the House who be Republicans would have
to vote for impeachment at least 19
Republicans in the Senate because of the
two-thirds constitutional requirement in
the Senate to remove a president from
office well what would that mean just
imagine what would it mean if such
substantial numbers of Republicans voted
to impeach and remove President Trump
from office it would splinter the
Republican Party that is the reality
would have many diehards on Capitol Hill
and across the country Republicans would
be furious at those Republicans who on
principle voted for impeachment and
removal if President Pence became a
reality he would become a reality
with a Republican Party behind him
that would be fractured that would be
way back on its heels and ultimately and
I'd sum it up this way
should we enable a dictatorship under
President Trump or should we go a
constitutional route on the basis that
no one should be above the law okay we
have a lot of calls waiting to talk to
you Ruth is calling from Columbia South
Carolina on our democratic line hi Ruth
hi how are you alright hi I'm calling um
because this is the first time I've
heard anything about impeachment but
I've been excellent now I'm wondering
when someone will be filing something
and I would also I have a question I
want to actually regarding our armed be
Congress isn't Congress supposed to step
in and um make some kind of change
because I believed that we had a
fail-safe mechanism in our Constitution
where they're supposed to back the
American people and realize that
something is not right
he has um even I know that you cannot
pay for a law a final bill to help
people deported just like that alright
let's let's let Norman Sullivan respond
Oh
well yes I think that more and more
people are going to be hearing the
constitutional grounds for impeachment
and that's one reason we have so much
information at impeach Donald Trump now
org on the web where people can not only
sign the petition if they so choose but
learn about impeachment and how it
applies in terms of a president Trump
now about your other point which i think
is also a very good one
there supposed to be a if you will as
you put it failsafe mechanism called
impeachment use rarely but essential as
was the case under President Nixon where
the Congress can't assert itself and
this is built in to the Constitution and
we are encouraged of course by the
administration to say that it should not
be pursued in this case but the Congress
needs to show some backbone here and I
mentioned the 46 percent to 46 percent
divided in the latest national polling
from Public Policy Polling a very
well-respected outfit a nationwide so if
you have the American people already
split and by the way that's from 35
percent to 46 percent support trendline
just in the last couple of weeks if the
American people already half of them who
have an opinion say that they believe
President Trump should be impeached why
is it that we don't have a single member
of Congress yet to step forward and
introduce a resolution for impeachment
and that goes to frankly if not
cowardice at least you know putting the
finger up to the wind that's not what we
need from members of Congress and so I
would encourage people watching and
listening to this discussion today on
c-span on Washington journal in the days
ahead your members of Congress the
person that represents you in the house
which constitutionally is to introduce
an impeachment resolution and act on it
they're going to be in your neighborhood
and it's your chance to tell them what
you think okay we are talking with
norman solomon co-founder of net of
roots
action dot org also executive director
and founder of the Institute for public
accuracy about a petition drive of to
impeach President Trump now the
Huffington Post reports that although
impeachment is a tough road that in a
long road that it may have gotten a
shorter in the case of President trumpet
says the momentum to impeach Donald
Trump xyx is accelerating on Thursday
congressman at Jerrold Nadler filed a
resolution of inquiry that amounts to
the first legislative step toward
impeachment a new poll shows that
registered voters are evenly split as
you mentioned 46 46 on whether they
support or oppose such an effort how
likely is this move by the congressman
going to step up the attention to this
well I think it's an important step you
know some folks perhaps with a dash of
cynicism but also realism think that
under the Capitol dome and on Capitol
Hill the members of the House and Senate
will be the last to realize what's going
on at the grassroots in this case
congressman Jerrold Nadler from New York
has taken an important step what's known
as an resolution of inquiry is something
that he has put forward and it begins to
insist if it's acted upon and the
Republican leadership seems to want to
stonewall it to use a term back from the
Nixon era but that resolution of inquiry
would require that the Attorney General
put forward detailed information about
the finances of President Trump so that
the American people and of course
members of Congress can have the
information to move forward so I would
applaud a representative Nadler on that
score but it's really inadequate because
we need a resolution of the impeachment
to be able to move forward in terms of
this national constitutional process and
and quickly remind our viewers of what
the process of impeachment entails yes
well after a resolution and this is
provided for in the Constitution the
resolution means that a congressional
committee and it's almost always and a
model resolution we have by the way on
our impeach Donald Trump now.org website
provides for
the resolution to bring the agenda to
the House Judiciary Committee and as the
dishy era jasiri committee that can then
move forward and have inquiry which in
this case according to the model
resolution that we put forward is not
only about the domestic and foreign
amendments clauses of the Constitution
but the scope could be widened depending
on where the investigation goes so it's
really up to the members of the house
okay John's calling in on our Republican
line from Nazareth Pennsylvania good
morning John good morning thank you for
taking my call
my question is to Norman Norman are you
Democrat and also do you feel getting a
petition for the against the president
is going to help the country now listen
let me explain something I grew up in
wings at Pennsylvania I grew up by a
terrorist group his name is Petula Gulen
he is from Turkey and why didn't you
come after mr. Obama or the Clintons
knowingly that they are helping a
terrorist group out of Staters for
Pennsylvania I grew up here there's a
man that does military training up there
there is no reason for what you're doing
you have no idea what you're doing as
you Spanish you're never put you on okay
let's let let's let mr. Sahni well I'm
not sure what your comments have to do
with impeachment about the incidents
that you as you described them anyway in
Pennsylvania I've had a variety of
registrations in terms of party
affiliation I'm currently a Democrat as
the co-founder and coordinator of
rootsaction.org I've overseen hundreds
of nationwide online actions that have
been very critical of Democratic Party
leadership and very critical by the way
a President Obama year after year during
his presence in the Oval Office so this
is not about partisanship and whatever
concerns people may have about terrorism
it is totally inappropriate to think
that our concerns should mean that the
Constitution of the United States should
be null and void and one other point on
that
president Trump has major investments in
Saudi Arabia and if you're going to look
at major sources of Wahhabi fanaticism
and terrorism and where most of the 9/11
hijackers came from that would be Saudi
Arabia so you might have some concern
about how the foreign emoluments Clause
of the US Constitution would create a
conflict of interest for the current man
behind the desk in the Oval Office
Linda's calling from Harrogate Tennessee
and our independent line Linda you're on
with Norman Sullivan thank you for
taking my call this right here man sound
like a Democrat nut and I did I was
gonna say something else but he didn't
come after the Kennedys and he should
would he have come after miss Clinton
when she raised money for her plan for
her campaign from Saudi Arabia keep it
at because I'd been more Democrat to
changing parties to Republicans there's
been about 1500 of them's already
changed insulation and I hope you keep
it up it makes it easier for me thank
you well thank you for your comment I
think it's so important that we have a
single standard a single standard on
constitutionality on presidential
conduct on human rights and partisanship
can be very corrosive often Republicans
and Democrats at least on Capitol Hill
they say one thing when their party is
in the White House the opposite when the
other parties in the White House we need
consistency that's why at
rootsaction.org we have consistently
criticized the Democratic Party as well
as the Republican party leadership when
they have been hypocritical when as you
mentioned the Clinton wing of the party
Hillary Clinton and the Clinton
Foundation quite a politicized one got
all sorts of money from middle-eastern
dictatorships and others so let's be
consistent here let's rise above
partisanship let's get the job done and
prevent dictatorship in this country and
have obedience to
in a proper way the Constitution of the
United States does any is any move to
impeach President Trump dependent upon
him releasing his tax returns this is
something he has not done so far I don't
think it requires that he released his
tax returns of course if the House
Judiciary Committee as it should
begins impeachment proceedings then it's
going to want to look at that sort of
financial information one of the notable
things about the foreign and domestic
amendments clauses is that the moment
not far from here
Donald Trump became President of the
United States he was in violation of
those two key clauses of the
Constitution so we don't need to see his
tax returns we don't need to get an
answer from some court somewhere it's a
legislative branch that is supposed to
move ahead with impeachment in the case
of such violations of the Constitution
by the president okay on our democratic
line Hillary is calling from Port Arthur
Texas good morning yes how you doing hi
hello no it's okay mr. Soloman oh you go
ahead yeah okay mr. on my part is you're
doing a great job and whatever call and
saying what he's saying they just I mean
you gotta get you got a hard no child to
hear all this but my point is the guy I
need to be impeached man it's too much
things that he's been doing and then
Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan just let
him get away with not now when Barack
Obama was in they Holly buddy want to
make my first time president notice
nobody I was talking about that Mitch
McConnell had said that and then but he
let this guy go in and just give him the
whole money and they do everything he's
doing with the money like hey they gotta
keep paying for him to keep going to
poor logo and all this and his kids I
understand all that but what about the
money on that daddy talk about this wall
in a way he's gonna do it all that was
just fan base stuff he told his friends
and they still believe it and it still
got some punch like ladies got off
earlier I mean how are you gonna go up
on you when you're trying to get them
and you're doing the right thing he
needs to be impeached we're gonna do
tomorrow every day we look at TV I look
at this channel c-span i watch CNN i
watch MSNBC I watch Morning Joe it's
like they keep trying to cover it up for
this guy tell you what take put it in
world
but many times again I got a Russian
ship sitting out there right now you
keep acting like you don't want to claim
Putin but it's just enough but that's
what yeah all right let's let a norman
solomon well thank you that i think it's
essential that we not normalize a
presidency that is moving towards
dictatorship with contempt for the law
including as i said the supreme law of
the land the constitution and it's
stunning to me and I don't live inside
the beltway I live in California but is
is really remarkable and notable that
when you get to Washington DC when you
get to the Capitol the concerns of so
many people around the country such as
what you just expressed are filtered out
or so to speak walled off and the
reality is when you have according to
polling fully half of the country now
just as supportive unequivocally for
impeachment as the other half is opposed
there is on Capitol Hill a sort of a
tone-deaf quality and it's time for I
equally call to account the Democratic
Party and Republican Party leadership
it's not the role of Nancy Pelosi to try
to prevent a constitutional process from
going forward and it's not the role of
elected members of the House to just
follow a party line you know if you're
going to have a bunch of birds alight on
a phone wire it first takes one and then
they may alight in droves and we need a
profile encourage a member of the House
to step forward with an impeachment
resolution
all right Stephens on the line from done
smart California and our Republican line
hi Stephen all right good morning thank
you very much
I love c-span and it's very early here
but I I'm a Republican
I suppose so or I used to be but I don't
support what's going on in Washington
this is crazy
my father is 91
my mother is 90 they are both alive and
both have to suffer through this and I
know we're going to be okay
but at the end of their lives why should
they have to suffer through this let's
get it done go ahead brother go get it
on thank you very much thank you for
that comment and Erica is calling from
San Diego on our democratic line hi
Erica hello hello I'm glad I got through
finally anyway I'm so impeachments I've
been screaming at my TV screen for a
long time a speech in Pete there were
things that I never hear mention any
place and that is that this man has all
his stuff made in China the products are
not made in this country
they meaning all over the world but not
in not in this country and the daughter
stuff is made in China and other places
and I don't want to take the talk too
long because I agree with the gentleman
here that
impeaches thank you very much well thank
you you know the domestic Amaya's clause
comes to the fore in so many ways for
instance the Trump International Hotel
just blocks from the White House has
just opened it is being leased with an
agreement from the General Services
Administration that explicitly says that
no elected official of the US government
can benefit from the lease and yet there
are many diplomats who have changed
their reservations to stay at the Trump
Hotel in Washington because they feel
that's more efficacious to gain the
attention of the US government and since
you mentioned China very briefly here
the state-owned Bank of China is the
largest lender to the Trump Organization
it is the largest tenant to the Trump
Towers in New York City and it's not
about jingoism it's about saying that
when the president is so involved and
immersed and entangled in the finances
of not only foreign governments but also
domestic entities where the article 2
section 7 explicitly forbids that kind
of entanglement with policies tax breaks
subsidies regulation actions by the US
government or
any one of the 50 states or the District
of Columbia then we have a huge
constitutional crisis brewing okay
norman solomon co-founder of
rootsaction.org thank you for joining us
today thank you hey